[Musique]
sur la côte ouest les tours de condos se
multiplient les prix de l'immobilier
atteignent la stratosphère
le rêve d'accès à la propriété devient
de plus en plus illusoire pour la classe
moyenne
bienvenue à vancouver où le marché
immobilier est devenu une cible du crime
organisé
[Musique]
écoute je ne sais pas combien une offre
mais c'était plusieurs jeux même pas
encore à combien s est vendu mais
c'était au dessus s'est vendu au prix
demandé
et puis c'était déjà 1 point 3
l'ingénieur québécois françois vitesse
et sa compagne marjolaine savoie se
cherche une nouvelle demeure mais même
pour des professionnels
vancouver est devenu presque hors de
prix françois vitesse visite des condos
et des duplex en banlieue de vancouver
il m'a pas les moyens d'acheter une
maison unifamiliale ce qu'on nous est
offert 1 998 1000 $ pour les enfants
aussi je vois pas comment ça peut
arrêter de monter ou jour comment ça
peut descendre
moi ce qui me préoccupe le plus c'est
mes enfants je peux pas m'imaginer une
profession légale qui peuvent faire ce
qu'ils veulent cela permet de rentrer
dans le marché même ses chiffres pour
les aider depuis dix ans la montée des
prix a été fulgurante
une maison unifamiliale moyenne du grand
vancouver coûte plus d'un million six
cent mille dollars
c'est presque quatre fois plus élevé que
dans le grand montréal
dans la ville de vancouver il n'y a
qu'une demi douzaine de maisons
unifamiliales
à moins d'un million de dollars comme
cette aubaine de l'est la ville à 869
mille dollars
et si vous êtes plus fortunés cette
demeure à retaper était vous pour la
rondelette somme de 2 millions cent
quarante mille dollars le revenu
familial médian à vancouver est à peine
plus élevé que celui de montréal
alors comment expliquer cette hausse
vertigineuse les bas taux d'intérêt
la spéculation et l'investissement
étranger ont tous contribué à alimenter
la bulle immobilière
mais un autre facteur important est venu
gonfler les prix le blanchiment d'argent
tout d'un coup il ya des acheteurs qui
sont prêts à payer des prix plus dur que
ce que le marché normalement permettrait
parce qu ils ne se servent à rien
à l'ombre des tours du centre ville se
trouve le d'anthony sadc milliers
toxicomanes
le trafic de la drogue comme le fentanyl
il fait des centaines de victimes à
chaque année personnes meurent chaque
année dans notre province
on sait le crime organisé qui alimentent
cette dépendance à la drogue la garde
des sceaux baril résultat beaucoup
d'argent comptant doit intégrer le
système financier pour être blanchi
selon un rapport d'experts mandatés par
la province jusqu'à cinq milliards de
dollars par année sont blanchis dans le
marché immobilier de la
colombie-britannique provoquant une
hausse du prix des maisons de 5% à
l'échelle provinciale pilote germain
était le sous-commissaire d'âge est
assez en colombie britannique
il a effectué deux études sur le
blanchiment d'argent
à la demande du gouvernement provincial
sorte d'avant on blanchit l'argent sale
grâce à un commerce où beaucoup de
transactions se font en argent comptant
les casinos sont parfaits pour ça voici
des images stupéfiantes captée dans des
casinos de la colombie-britannique des
joueurs venus de chine échange des
dizaines de milliers voire des centaines
de milliers de dollars en argent
comptant contre des jetons de casino
on y voit des liasses de billets tenus
par des élastiques comme le font les
trafiquants de drogue
une part des fonds blanchis dans les
casinos se retrouve dans l'immobilier
vous ne verrez pas de sacs d'argent
comptant chez les courtiers immobiliers
des fonds qui aboutissent dans
l'immobilier ont déjà été placées dans
le système financier
mais selon peter german des sommes
encore plus importantes proviennent
directement de l'étranger par virement
électronique sans qu'on pût sans
vérifier l'origine ces fonds sont
envoyés dans les comptes bancaires
d'avocats canadien et contrairement aux
banquiers et aux agents immobiliers les
avocats ne sont pas tenus de signaler
des transactions douteuses aux autorités
fédérales en raison du secret
professionnel
c'est l'un un trou béant dans le système
de surveillance canadien
l'argent déposé dans les comptes en
fiducie des avocats est invisible pour
les policiers
oui cola beaucoup d'argent sale pourrait
ainsi entrer au pays ne sais quoi car on
est incapable de voir où ces fonds entre
dans le système financier
mais cet argent va directement dans
l'immobilier en 2010 est un avocat de
west vancouver a été suspendu par le
barreau de la colombie britannique
il a utilisé son compte en fidéicommis
pour transférer au nom de clients près
de 26 millions de dollars provenant de
paradis fiscaux sans se renseigner
adéquatement sur les circonstances la
transaction et sur l'origine des fonds
nos avocats et d'autres actions que même
le d'érable ce genre de transaction
mais la majorité d'entre eux puna mains
sales très bien qu'il ya des questions
qui ne doit proposer à nos clients et
puis ils vont continuer à procéder comme
si rien n'était
de plus l'utilisation de prête-noms pour
dissimuler les véritables propriétaires
est courant en colombie britannique
selon l'analyse de peter james plus de
33000 demeure ont été achetés par des
personnes qui se disent chômeurs
étudiants ou femme au foyer dis pas que
ces gens ne peuvent pas acheter une
maison
mais c'est peu probable car il s'agit
surtout de maisons de grande valeur ce
sont probablement des prête-noms sont
déjà en colombie britannique
la grc avait une équipe d'une vingtaine
de personnes consacrées à la lutte au
blanchiment d'argent
mais cette équipe a été démantelé en
[Musique]
c'est un problème pour combattre ces
crimes complexe il faut des équipes
intégrées comme on avait à ras des gens
formés en comptabilité ou en droit et
qui sont aussi des enquêteurs qui est
dit fier quel est le risque pour les
à-peu-près pas c'est un secret de
polichinelle il ya très peu de banques
est qu'ils sont raides sont menées et
raccords encore - dunkerque sont menées
avec succès pour s'attaquer au problème
le gouvernement a constitué une
commission d' enquête sur le blanchiment
d'argent et dès le mois de juin
un registre révélant les propriétaires
réels des biens immobiliers sera
instauré une première au canada
mais lorsque les activités du crime
organisé sont exposés au grand jour les
criminels changent leurs méthodes ou des
places leurs activités de blanchiment
vers d'autres provinces
howard est ce qui rend vancouver
attrayante pour le blanchiment d'argent
se retrouve aussi à montréal les gens
québec devrait considérer ça comme
signal dallas
[Musique]
e
je
[Musique]